Якось мені зробили комплімент: "А ти симпатична як для єврейки".
Проявів антисемітизму значно більше, ніж люди собі зазвичай уявляють.
Анна - дослідниця онкозахворювань у Мюнхені.
А Дорон - суддя у Берліні.
Якщо для інших антисемітизм - газетний заголовок, для них – це повсякдення:
дискримінація лише тому, що вони - євреї.
Це актуальна реальна проблема. Вона нікуди не поділася.
Від натяків до відкритого насильства: антисемітизм має багато проявів.
І часом виявляєш його в самому собі - мимохіть.
Не обов'язково треба мати злий намір, щоб сказати щось антисемітське.
Я б віднесла себе до ліберального юдаїзму.
Наша громада орієнтується на традиції.
Був у нас тут яскравий випадок – це коли хтось їздив велосипедом та мотоциклом
навколо синагоги і кричав "Хайль Гітлер!", у той час, коли дітей відводять до дитячого садка.
Тобто о 8:30 ранку, коли тут збирається багато батьків.
А потім мені видали на одній вечірці: "Одну Гітлер забув, чи що?"
Як самопроголошений "фюрер" нацистської Німеччини Адольф Гітлер
відповідальний за систематичне вбивство шести мільйонів євреїв.
Як поводитися в такій ситуації єврейці чи єврею? - Ну, я спочатку розгубилася.
У мене якось була зустріч, йшлося про репортаж для одного відомого німецького журналу,
і вже наприкінці, за чашкою кави - зовсім неочікуване питання:
"Ну, а тепер, якщо чесно, у євреїв завжди все крутиться навколо грошей, хіба ні?"
І я подумав: секунду, мені точно не почулося?
І це лише ОДИН із багатьох вікових забобонів. Адже:
Вони спливають знову і знову: одні й ті ж потворні історії, лише у новій упаковці.
Існує безліч різних варіантів антисемітизму.
Мір'ям Венцель, директорка єврейського музею у Франкфурті.
То звідки ж узялося кліше про нібито багатство євреїв?
Історично так склалося, що євреї у Європі не мали доступу до багатьох професій.
Водночас їм можна було займатися торгівлею монетами та обміном грошей.
Уявлення про те, що євреї завжди пов'язані з грошима, зародилося в початковий період епохи Нового часу.
Особливо плідний ґрунт для антисемітських стереотипів з'являється у кризові часи.
Напевно, найвідоміша антисемітська теорія змови - це так звана "невидима рука":
Ви не можете її побачити, вона невидима, але є припущення, що це щось моторошне, що працює таємно.
Арі Дубнов - професор історії Колумбійського університету Джорджа Вашингтона.
Навіть під час пандемії коронавірусу цю теорію змови знову розганяли.
Ці питання про те, кому ж вигідний ковід.
А потім натяки, що це ж змова євреїв, бізнесменів та компаній, які виробляють вакцини.
І так далі, і так далі…
Невелика група людей, які потай правлять світом - доволі зручне для багатьох уявлення, з давньою традицією.
Це, звісно, головний антисемітський наратив. І він - християнський.
Чутки про "невидиму руку" ходять ще з часів Середньовіччя.
Християни тоді хотіли поширити свою релігію по всій Європі і переслідували євреїв.
А це означає, що теорія змови про те, що євреї роблять щось таємно,
завжди мобілізує емоції, які потім, у свою чергу, призводять до актів насильства.
Особисто я стикаюся з цим дуже часто, і мені просто цікаво,
про що насправді говорять німці за якоюсь різдвяною сімейною вечерею, коли заходить мова про антисемітські теорії змови?
Чи мовчать вони чи все ж таки щось говорять?
Так, говорити про це варто. Адже:
Але чому саме німцям так важко розбиратися з антисемітизмом?
Можливо, тому, що вони думають, що успішно розпрощалися з ним у минулому?
Мені здається, що багато хто пов'язує антисемітизм виключно з Другою світовою війною та уявленням,
що антисемітизм винайшов Гітлер і все закінчилося 1945 року. Але це зовсім не відповідає історії.
Якщо коротко:
Ба більше, євреї піддавалися систематичним переслідуванням,
насильницькому наверненню до інших релігій та вигнанню протягом століть.
Проте нацистська диктатура була безпрецедентно жорстокою.
З приходом до влади Гітлера в 1933 євреїв у Німеччині
дедалі більше виключали із суспільного життя шляхом антисемітських законів.
Антисемітська пропаганда взагалі не вважала євреїв людьми.
У Німеччині та окупованій нацистами Європі євреїв замикали у гетто
та депортували до концентраційних таборів, катували та систематично вбивали.
Якщо ми дійсно хочемо боротися з антисемітизмом,
не варто завжди використовувати Голокост як стандарт для порівняння.
Ми радше маємо уважно придивитися: а як проявляється дискримінація у повсякденному житті?
Що це за маленькі мовні обороти, ментальні упередження - які далеко не одразу означають вбивство?
Наче антисемітом можна вважати лише того, хто виступає за відправку євреїв до газових камер,
а все, що не заходить так далеко, вже стає легітимною критикою та дискусією з цього питання.
Якщо коротко:
Однак виражатися він може і в такій формі:
"А ти симпатична як для єврейки".
Але що це означає у повсякденному житті?
Ти помічаєш це, коли бабуся дає тобі мацу на Песах, ти кладеш її в машину, а бабуся каже:
"Ні, ніколи не клади на видноті, сховай. Я не хочу, щоб мій сусід помітив, що ми - євреї".
У колі моїх друзів багато євреїв, які відкрито не говорять про свою етнічну чи релігійну приналежність,
тому що вони стикалися з антисемітизмом.
Для мене це стрес - постійно щось приховувати,
і я завжди говорю відкрито про те, що я єврейка.
І якщо у когось виникають проблеми із цим, вони мають просто обговорити їх зі мною.
Думаю, реагувати можна по-різному, це також залежить від людини,
а іноді по-різному реагує навіть та сама людина.
Відчуття - "час діставати валізи" або "на часі більш реально оцінювати те, що тут відбувається".
Чи можу я дійсно бути частиною тутешнього суспільства в довгостроковій перспективі,
чи достатньо я захищений? Куди це веде?
Місце, де багато євреїв почуваються в безпеці - це Ізраїль, єдина єврейська держава світу.
З 1950 року євреї з усього світу, а також новонавернені до юдаїзму,
мають право жити в Ізраїлі та стати громадянами цієї держави.
Для мене як віруючої єврейки має значення, що там я можу відкрито відзначати єврейські свята.
З одного боку, це місце, де можна сховатися, і відчуття, що є така країна;
з іншого боку - просто можливість побути там трохи і не відчувати, що ти у меншості.
Історично Ізраїль має велике значення для євреїв.
Адже навіть просто ходити вулицею зі своєю зіркою Давида і знати,
що нічого не станеться, - це вже неймовірне почуття для єврея чи єврейки.
Однак після заснування держави Ізраїль виник новий різновид антисемітизму: антисемітизм щодо Ізраїлю.
Та ж сумна картина спостерігається у всьому світі:
якщо в заголовках газет домінує близькосхідний конфлікт, кількість антисемітських нападів зростає.
Щойно в Ізраїлі виникає конфлікт, настрій відразу стає більш жорстким, неприємним і тут.
Мене завжди спантеличує, що інші люди, коли я говорю, що єврейка,
починають критикувати мене за політику Ізраїлю або вважають мене відповідальною за неї.
Я не маю ізраїльського паспорта, я не можу там голосувати.
Я не можу вплинути на політичну ситуацію там, я не ізраїльтянка.
Більшість євреїв не є ізраїльтянами - у багатьох немає взагалі жодного зв'язку з Ізраїлем.
Коли мене запитують: що, на твій погляд, відбувається зараз в Ізраїлі?
Без обвинувального тону і підтексту: "Що ти і твій народ знову коїте?"
Якщо просто запитують: "Як ти це оцінюєш?" - то, звичайно, я відповідаю нормально,
але саме тон все й визначає.
А тому треба усвідомити, що:
Звичайно, критикувати ізраїльський уряд можна.
Але де межа між антисемітизмом і політичними дебатами?
Якщо, наприклад, демонстрація проходить перед синагогою,
а не перед посольством Ізраїлю, грань уже починає стиратися.
І це одна з головних проблем, яка полягає в тому, що дуже часто критика політики уряду Ізраїлю
додатково ставить під сумнів саме право на існування єврейської держави.
Або інший типовий випадок: коли від євреїв автоматично очікують,
що вони висловлюватимуться щодо Ізраїлю - хочуть вони цього чи ні.
Ви за чи проти того-то й того-то? До чого ви лояльні?
І тут треба чітко говорити: це вже не на межі, а очевидний антисемітизм.
Тому що в такому разі люди виходять з того, що кожен єврей у певному сенсі є представником ізраїльського уряду.
Тема, на якій легко обпектися. Але що робити? Взагалі не говорити про уряд Ізраїлю та його політику?
Саме тому я завжди трохи насторожено ставлюся до таких закидів: "Про Ізраїль взагалі говорити не можна".
Звісно, Ізраїль близький нам, і, звичайно, для більшості з нас він важливіший, ніж багато інших країн.
І говорити про нього - це абсолютно нормально.
Отже:
А от змішувати ізраїльську політику та життя євреїв у всьому світі - неправильно і часто є антисемітизмом.
Завдяки соціальним мережам антисемітські упередження в наші дні поширюються буквально за лічені секунди.
Це як дрібний шрифт на кожній упаковці продуктів харчування: читайте його уважно!
Тільки тому що у "Фейсбуку" чи деінде щось стверджується, а інші це повторюють, це ще не є правильним.
На жаль, часто навпаки.
Тож, як завжди:
З антисемітизмом євреї стикаються у всьому світі.
І це завжди одні й ті самі стереотипи, одні й ті самі упередження, та сама ненависть.
Боротися із цим важко.
Але бути євреєм означає набагато більше.
Це, можливо, те, що слід робити: намагатися робити фокус на поточне активне життя єврейської громади
і показувати, що відбувається насправді.
Адже і для євреїв завжди існує велика небезпека того,
що вони можуть почати мислити виключно в цих вимірах і забути про позитивні сторони.
Особисто я взагалі не можу себе ототожнювати з роллю жертви.
Я завжди відкрито ношу свою зірку Давида, пишаюся тим, що я єврейка.
І вулицями Мюнхена я ходжу як горда єврейка.